شرعت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
التحقيق بشان تسريب وثائق فائقه السريه
تتعلق بالنزاع في اوكرانيا وقال جون كيربي
منسق الاتصال الاستراتيجي في مجلس الامن
القومي ان واشنطن تتعامل مع الامر بجديه
وتبحث تاثيره على الامن القومي للبلاد
واضاف ان الاداره الامريكيه ستجري مشاورات
مع حلفائها بشان تداعيات تلك التسريبات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي حيثيات تسريب
وثائق فائقه السريه من البنتاجون تمثل شكل
الاحاطات المقدمه لكبار القاده ما مدى
حساسيتها وخطورتها على الامن القومي
الامريكي ومن المستفيد من كل ذلك ما حجم
تاثير هذه التسريبات على استراتيجيه الغرب
في دعم اوكرانيا ومسار المعارك مع روسيا
وعلى علاقات الولايات المتحده بحلفائها
وكيف ينظر حلفاء واشنطن على الى مدى
خطورتها وانعكاساتها عليهم وما هي
تقديراتهم لحجم الضرر والتداعيات
[موسيقى]
بشروعها في تحقيقات حول الوثائق المسربه
من البنتاجون بشان عدد من الملفات تعد حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا من اهمها تحاول
الاداره الامريكيه عبر وزاره العدل
استدراك امرها على جبهتين الاولى معرفه
ملابسات التسريبات والوقوف على الثغرات
التي سمحت بذلك اما على الجبهه الثانيه
فتتواصل مع دول حليفه لتوضيح ما كشفته بعض
الوثائق المسربه من اعتراض الولايات
المتحده اتصالات لقاده فيها المسؤولون
الامريكيون وان لم يسلموا بصحه كل الوثائق
متحدثين عن امكانيه ان يكون قد جرى
تغييرها او استخدامها كجزء من حمله تضليل
فانهم تعاهدوا بالتحقيق في التسريبات لما
تتضمنه من حرج دواشنطن من قبيل ما تم كشفه
من معلومات عن مساعده الولايات المتحده
وحلف شمال الاطلسي لاوكرانيا وتقييم
المخابرات الامريكيه لحلفاء واشنطن وهو ما
قد يغضبهم تقرير لموقع ذاهل نقل عن
مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم ان روسيا او عناصر
مواليه لها هم على الارجح وراء الدفعه
الاولى من التسريبات على الاقل
[موسيقى]
لمناقصه هذا الموضوع معنا
من لاري كوربا مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه السابق وكبير الباحثين في مركز
التقدم الامريكي والدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
والباحث في المركز العربي في واشنطن اهلا
وسهلا
هذه الوثائق المماثله لاحاطات تقدم لكبار
المسؤوليين المسؤولين ومدى
حساسيه هذه التسريبات وما سرب منها حتى
الان
[موسيقى]
يعطينا فكره عما تفعله وتفكر به الولايات
المتحده حول الحرب في اوكرانيا وما يفعله
الاخرون لمساعده في معرفه ماده الضرر
الاصابه روسيا واصابه اوكرانيا في هذه
الحرب وكذلك تتناول موضوع كوريا الجنوبيه
واسرائيل ومصر فمثلا حقيقه ان مصر ربما
تفكر بارسال تجهيزات الى روسيا هذا امر
اكتشاف وما قيل عن كوريا الجنوبيه من
اسلحه يقدمونها الولايه المتحده سوف تنتهي
بايدي بايدي اوكرانيا وهذا هم مباشره بشكل
مباشر
ما يحصل فيما في سعيد مع القيام العسكريين
بعدم تعبير عن عدم رضاه عما يقوم به
نتنياهو وسياسته
لتقليل دور القضاء في اسرائيل اذا ان هذا
كله يشمل تقييمات لما تفكر به اجهزه
الاستخبارات هنا في بلادنا وحول كثير من
القضايا وحقيقه الامر ان هذه ليست اول مره
نجد ان معلومات سريه امريكيه تسربت فهناك
قبل خمس سنوات هناك ايضا وفي بدايه
السبعينات اوراق قد ظهرت وسكان فيها
التفاصيل كثيره حول حرب فيتنام التي لم
تكن قد نشرت سابقا دكتور خليل هل من
الدقيقه ان نقول انما حدث يمثل ثغره خطيره
في الامن القومي الامريكي وان الاخطر ان
السلطات الامريكيه لا تعرف حتى الان من
كان وراء هذه التسريبات
نعم الى حد بعيد نحن واحده من اخطر عمليات
الاختراق او التجسس او كشف المعلومات
السريه التي تحدث منذ على الاقل عقد من
الزمن نتكلم على ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه الجزء
المتعلق بحجم وكم هذه الوثائق حتى هذه
اللحظه تم الكشف عن على الاقل 100 وثيقه
ما بين سريه وسريه للغايه واحد هناك حديث
حول مئات الوثائق التي سوف يتم نشرها خلال
الفتره المقبله الامر الثاني متعلق
بالمضمونه المحتوى والنطاق وبما يعني ليس
فقط الامر متعلق بخطط الحرب الموجوده في
اوكرانيا فيما يتعلق باستعداد القوات
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه فيما
يتعلق بالدعم الاوكراني وفيما يتعلق
بالحمله القادمه بعد شهر من الايام يطلق
عليه او الحمله المضاده الاوكراني على
روسيا بلد الامر متعلق بالحلفاء امريكا
كما ذكر قبل قليل بيتكلم على حلفاء وتقل
امريكا اسرائيل كندا كوريا الجنوبيه
الامارات ومصر هؤلاء هناك تسريبات خاصه
تامر يحدث ضد امريكا وعلاقات عشان المثال
مثلا بين الامارات وبين روسيا تبادل
استخباراتي على مستوى عالي جدا هناك ايضا
حديث حول امكانيه قيام مصر
وامداد روسيا بما يقدر باربعين الف قاذفه
صاروخ من خلال انتاج مصنع مصنع المصنع
الحربي في مصر نتكلم ايضا على تسريب متعلق
بالتحريض الاسرائيلي للمواطنين
الاسرائيليين ولضباط المساعد بالتظاهر ضد
نتانياه وفيما يتعلق بما يعرف بالاصلاح
القضائي بنتكلم ايضا على تسريب خطير جدا
فيما يتعلق بالموقف القريه الكوريا
الجنوبيه الجنوبيه في موقف حرج الان لم
تسريبات تقول انها من جهه كانها قدغوت
امريكيه عليها من اجل تقديم اسلحه فتاكه
لاوكرانيا في نفس الوقت هناك سياسه متبعه
منذ 50 عام على الاقل لدى كوريا الجنوبيه
تتعلق بعدم تقديم اسلحه فتاكه لدول في
حاله حرب وبالتالي الامر يضع هذا يضع
امريكا في اطار نوع من الحرج الدولي مع
هذه الدوله الامر الثالث
متعلق بتدعيات ذلك على مستقبل العلاقات
الامريكيه مع حلفاء مع حلفاء حلفائه اعتقد
نحن في هذه اللحظه نتحدث هناك محاولات
امريكيه لتقليل حجم الدمج او الدرج الذي
نتج نادي التسريبات حتى هذه اللحظه نعم
السيد لاريكورد دائما في مثل هذه الحالات
يقال ابحث عن المستفيد ما نقله موقع داهل
عن مسؤولين امريكيين من انهم لا يستبعدون
ان تكون روسيا وراء هذه التسريبات في
اعتقادك هل يشكل هذا قناعه واسعه لدى
المسؤولين الامريكيين على المستويين
السياسي والامني في الولايات المتحده
هناك اي شكمان روسيا ربما لعبت دورا في
هذا الامر لانه عندما ظهرت الوثائق هذه
كان لديهم عدد اكبر من الضحايا التي كانت
تكبتها روسيا ثم قلل الرقم الى رقم غير
واقعي وبالتالي لهذا ما يجب ان نتاكد منه
هل ان هذا شخص في الولايات المتحده اعطى
هاي المعلومات لروسيا لاخراجهم ام اثناء
كم كان يقول للروسيا بانهم سوف يحصل ذلك
ربما هذا جاسوس لدينا نحن في روسيا شارك
في هذا الامر اذا نعم هذا من الواضح امر
لابد ان دراسته بالتمعن واذا ما فعلا كانت
روسيا هي الضالعه في الامر الفاضي على
اكثر خطوره من مجرد ان هناك شخص مثل سنودن
او غيره الذي هو كان السياسات الامريكيه
مع معلومات
الشخص له طرف في الحرف هذا اكثر خطوره لم
نجد تحقيق انه لنعرف ربما روسيا قد تغلغلت
داخل مؤسسات الاستخباريه دكتور خليل انت
في واشنطن من خلال متابعتك كيف يتفاعل
الراي العامل الامريكي مع هذه التسريبات
هل هذا التفاعل هو بمستوى الخطوره التي
توصف بها هذه التسريبات والحرج الذي قد
تسببه لحلفاء الولايات المتحده
على الاقل في الدوره الرسميه هناك قلق
متزايد هناك تصريحات متزايده كل ساعه
تقريبا هناك حديث حول اما فتح تحقيقات
واما محاوله تهدئه مخاوف الحلفاء واما
استدعاء بعض المسؤولين للشهاده في
الكونغرس لامريكا وبالتالي هناك حاله قلق
يعني متواصله بشكل عام هناك شعور متزايد
بان هذه التسريبات تمثل يعني خطوره عاليه
ليس فقط لما تحتويه ايضا التوقيت توقيت
مهم جدا من عده جوانب بجانب الاوامر متعلق
كما قلت قبل قليل هناك استعدادات على قدم
وساق من خلال دعم امريكي ودعم غربي خاصه
حلف النيتو لاوكرانيا هناك خطه للقيام
بعمليه مضاده كان هدف منها محاوله استعاده
اقليم د احتلاله قبل حوالي عام من الان
وبالتالي هناك عمليه كشف لسريه هذه
العمليات وهذا يعتبر لحد بعيد ضربه قاسمه
لقوات اوكرانيا والقوات التحالف لانه
يعتبر نوع من الكشاف امام القوات الروسيه
التي سوف تقوم الان بالاستفاده من هذه
المعلومات وبالتالي اعاده تموضع قوتها
خاصه في بخموت ومناطق اخرى التي يعتدي
فيها الصراع الان الامر الثاني متعلق
بالصراع الصين عندما يقوم الان احد
الاشخاص وهناك ايضا حديث يعني او هناك
سناريرات مختلفه استاذ عثمان حول الامر
متعلق اما باختراق روسي واما بتواطؤ
لمسؤول سابق او حالي في الاداره الامريكيه
سواء كان في يعني مكان حساس وقد يكون
الثالث لم يتم التركه اليه قبل ذلك وهو
متعلق بالصين قد يكون هناك تدخل صيني او
دور صيني في هذه المساله من مصلحه السيره
ان يكون هناك نوع من التوتر ليس فقط فيما
يتعلق بالحرب رساله اوكرانيا ايضا في
التوتر بين امريكا وحلفائها خاصه في الظل
ما يشاع حول انسحاب امريكا المنطقه
العربيه منطقه الشرق الاوسط وعدد تموضع
بشكل او باخر مستفيده بشكل مساله فيما
يتعلق بداخل امريكا هناك حاله تفاعل
مستمره اعتقد هناك محاوله لملمه هذه
المساله وهناك طبعا بشكل مستمر حذف لهذه
الوثائق ونعتقد خلال الفتره اللي جايه
خلال اسابيع القادمه بيتكلم على فتح
تحقيقات اكثر من ذلك ومحاوله استدعاء
مسؤولين من اجل معرفه السبب في ذلك
وبالتالي تقليل دمج التي نتج عن هذه
التسريبات حتى هذه اللحظه السيد لاري كورب
يعني كما اشاره الدكتور خليل المعلومات
التي نشرت فيما يتعلق بحرب اوكرانيا وكما
قال خاض امريكيون في حقيقه الامر هي
معلومات حساسه جدا وبالتالي نشر هذه
المعلومات على نطاق واسع كيف يمكن ان يؤثر
على خطط الغرب في هذه الحرب
الشكه في ذلك فهذا امر طبعا لا يساعد على
دور النيتو ولايه المتحده
وحلفاء الثلاثين في اوروبا في هذه الحرب
فهناك اشخاص في بعض هذه الدول كما شاهدنا
زياده ماكرون الى الصين الذي
بعدم سعادته ان تسير هذه الحرب والدعوه
الى تسويتها اذا كل هذه المجتمعات
الديمقراطيه التي فيها احزاب معارضه يمكن
ان يستخدموا هذه المعلومات للدعوه الى
اجنده تختلف عن جده لدينا حاليا وبالتالي
ربما هذا هو السبب انه الذي سرب هذا
المعلومات اذا كان فقط شخص امريكي ام
امريكي مع شخص اخر يتشاطر معلومات
استخباريه معه حاول تحقيق هذا الهدف هذا
هو عاده ما يحصل عندما نشاهد التسري تسريب
مثل هذه المعلومات اثناء حرب جاريه
دكتور خليل هذه اجواء حرب في كل الاحوال
وامورك هذه يمكن ان تتوقع وهناك دائما
مستفيد اداء الولايات المتحده على هذا
الصعيد كيف بدا لك
لحظه مرتبط اداء ضعيف وهذه التسريبات تكشف
رضا عثمان ما كنا نقوله على مدار الاسابيع
والشهور الماضيه اداره ضعيفه اداره مهتزه
هناك حاله استخفاف واستهتار بها من قبل
اهم حلفائها وراينا وقرانا اليوم وحضرتك
فضلت في بدايه المقدمه عندما تحدثت عن
الوثيقه المسربه بين التحالف او بين على
الاقل التعاون استخباراتي على اعلى مستوى
بين الاستخبارات الروسيه والاستخبارات
الاماراتيه فيما يتعلق بتحريض روسيا
للامارات على تضليل المخابرات البريطانيه
المخابرات الامريكيه هذا يعتبر تطور خطير
جدا فيما يتعلق العلاقات الثنائيه بين
الامارات وبين امريكا من جهه اخرى كما قلت
قبل قليل نتكلم على حلفاء على مستوى عالي
من الاهميه لامريكا سواء اسرائيل او كوريا
الجنوبيه او حتى كندا هناك تسريب فيما
يتعلق بكندا فيما يتعلق يعني الحصول على
اشعارات او على احداثيات انبوب الغاز
الكندي وهذا يعتبر ايضا تسريب خطير الامر
قد يكون مختلف هذه المره من حيث التوقيت
ومن حيث بشكل عام ستمر هذه الازمه كم
سابقتها وذكرنا قبل قليل لك تسريبات شهيره
جدا في ويكيليكس قبل حوالي 13 عام من الان
وتسريبات في 2013 قبل 10 سنوات من الان
التي ادت الى ضرر في علاقات الامريكيه
الغربيه خاصه مثلا لو على سبيل المثال
العلاقات الالمانيه الامريكيه عندما تم
الكشف عن التجسس على الالمانيه السابقه
انجيلا ميركل وكذلك تجسس على رئيس
البرازيل والتجسس على قاده الدول الغربيه
اخرى وبالتالي هذا يعتبر اختراق كبير جدا
يؤثر بشكل على مستوى الثقه بين امريكا
وبين حلفها سواء في الغرب او في المنطقه
العربيه
اذا ما قررنا بين روسيا والولايات المتحده
على هذا الصعيد فما الذي تقوله هذه
المقارنه هل تبدو الولايات المتحده اقل
تحصنا انجاز التعبير فيما يخص
مخازنها الامنيه والسياسيه
حقيقه الامر لان الولايات المتحده هي
مجتمع مفتوح لدينا حريه صحافه لا نستطيع
ان نوقف الصحافه من نشره هذه المعلومات
اما روسيا فهي تسيطر على كل المعلومات
والاعلام
وبالتالي هذا امر يحصل في غالبا في بلادنا
ولكن اعتقد على المدى البعيد نحن اقوى في
هذا الجانب لان ذلك يجعلنا ناقش قضايا
ينبغي ان نفكر بيها ان مازلنا نريد تقديم
مليار دولار مساعدات الى مصر اذا ما كانت
مصر تقدم صواريخ الى الى روسيا على سبيل
المثال وبالتالي اعتقد انه من الهمهام ان
تخرج هذه المعلومات ولكن حقيقه الامر ان
هذه المعلومات لم تخرج بشكل قانوني ولسوء
الحظ هذا ادى وسبب مشاكل
ومره اخرى انا اشعر بقلق ازاء الناس اللي
عملنا في حكومتنا الذي اعتذر هذا الامر
موجود على وسائل التواصل منذ الشهر الم
يكن يتابعوا ذلك هل يعيشون في عالم ليس
فيه تواصل اجتماعي التواصل كان معلومات
مشهوره منذ شهر الناس تحصل على معلوماتها
من اخبار جميع وسائل نعم الحلفاء حلفاء
الولايات المتحده حصلوا على هذه المعلومات
دكتور خليل العناني كيف تعتقد ان هذه
التسريبات يمكن ان تؤثر على العلاقات
الامريكيه مع حلفاء الولايات المتحده الان
وقد علموا كيف ان واشنطن تعترض بعض
انشطتهم وكيف يمكن لامريكا ان ان تطمئن
حلفائها بعد هذه التسريبات
انا اعتقد لابد ان نفرق بين مستويين من
التاثير او التاثر مستوى مستوى المدى
القصير والمدى الطويل على المدى القصير قد
يكون هناك نوع من التضرر او نوع من
المشاكل في العلاقات الامريكيه مع حلفائها
خاصه الحلفاء اللي يعتبروا الى حد بعيد
هناك حالا من التحالف الاستراتيجي كما قلت
قبل قليل سواء كان علاقه مع اسرائيل او
العلاقه مع الامارات او علاقه زي مصر
تعتبر حليف استراتيجي مهم جدا لامريكا او
كوريا الجنوبيه او كندا هناك ضرر اكيد حدث
وهناك تصور سيزيد مساله عدم الثقه بين
الطرفين كما حدث قبل ذلك عندما تم تسريب
ايضا قبل 10 سنوات كما قلت قبل قليل في
تضرر في العلاقات الالمانيه الامريكيه لكن
بشكل عثمان على ما يبدو التسريبات نحن
ازاء عمليه تامر وعمليه تجسس متبادله جميع
تجسس على الجميع وجميع تامر على الجميع
يعني الامارات ومصر يتامران على امريكا من
خلف ظهرها مع روسيا وامريكا تتامر او
تتجسس على حلفائها سواء في المنطقه
العربيه في منطقه جنوب شرق اسيا او في
اوروبا او في كندا وبالتالي وكان هناك حرب
استخباراتيه وكان هناك عدم ثقه بين كل هذه
الاطراف بين بعضها البعض على العكس يبدو
ظاهريا على مستوى المدى الطويل اعتقد لا
تزال العلاقه الامريكيه مع هذه البلدان
علاقه استراتيجيه علاقه مهمه جدا علاقه
حيويه حتى وان بدا ان هناك حتى هذه اللحظه
نوع من
الانزعاج من الانسحاب الامريكي المنطقه
العربيه حتى وان بدا هناك ظهور بديل لقوه
دوليه وهي الصين فيما يتعلق بالعمق
الاستراتيجي الدولي الى انه تطلع العلاقات
الامريكيه من حلفاء علاقات مهمه
واستراتيجيه تعود لعقود وبتعمل الصعب ان
تتاثر على مستوى الطويل قد يحدث على مستوى
القصير خاصه اذا كان هناك يعني تسريبات
اخرى سوف تظهر خلال الاسابيع القادمه لكن
بشكل عام اعتقد ان هناك جهد امريكي محموم
من اجل تطمنت هؤلاء وعلى الاقل محاوله
لملمه اثار هذه تداعيات هذه التسريبات على
مدى القصير السيد السيد قرب بالفعل يعني
هناك مفاجات كل يوم هل نتوقع ان تظهر
مفاجات جديده من خلال هذه التسريبات ان
تعتقد ان الامر قد تم تطبيقه عند هذا الحد
هناك بالتاكيد معلومات تظهر يوميا
وتبين طريقه عمل حكومتنا وطريقه الريال
الحرب الناس استغربوا كيف الاوكرانيين
ايقاف الروسي
وصلتم تجهيزات خمسين دوله تساعد اوكرانيا
كما اننا استغربنا وليس سعداء بالدور
التركي في هذا الموضوع ويبدو ان حتى ان
مصر لها دور نعم اذا هناك امور لابد ان
نتعامل معها ولكن اعتقد على المدى البعيد
جميع الناس ان يكون اقوى نتيجه هذا لان
ظهرت كثير الامور التي في الواقعيه ينبغي
ان تناقش ان ونفكر بها ونحن نقوم
بسياساتنا
اعتقد ان هناك حلفاء
يستنتجون بالم يحتاجوننا وانها سفع
القصارى جهدنا
لنبقى معهم لكن الامور ليست مثاليه لم
ابدا وكما قلت سابقا لو عدنا الى ويكيليكس
اوت او تشيلسي كثير الامور التي تظهر
وكما حصل معك التسريبات واوراق ووثائق
الفانتا المتحده فقط حتى استراليا
والكوريين اللي كان يحاولون معهم
الدكتور خليل باختصار لو سمحت لابد ان
تكون هناك محاسبات وربما عقوبات هل تعتقد
ان الولايات المتحده سوف تكتفي بالمسار
الخارجي ما هي الدائره التي تعتقد ان ان
تصل الي هذه المحاسبه
انا اعتقد مهما كان المحاسبه سوف الامر في
طي الكتمان وطري السريه هذا يعتبر نوع من
انكشاف الامريكي للخارج اللي تم اكتشاف ان
متسبب في ذلك طرف داخلي امريكا تفتم
محاسبته بلا شك نحن
ايضا يتم الحديث عنه وقد يكون التسريب ده
حدث من خلال دوله حليفه لامريكا بمعنى اخر
نعلم جميعا هناك ما يسمى او العيون الخمسه
هناك عمليه تشارك استخباراتي بين دول خمسه
هي امريكا
وكندا وبريطانيا ونيوزلندا لا يستبعد ان
يكون احد هذه البلدان او احد المسؤولين
فيها واحد العاملين بجازات اجهزه الامن
القومي بها قد قام بهذا التصريب او الاخر
وبالتالي اذا تم استكشاف ذلك سوف يتم هذا
دفع امريكا العهد تقييم هذه المساله
وبالتالي حتى النظر في مشاركه المعلومات
واستهباراتيه مع هذه البلدان لكن بشكل عام
على المدى القصير هناك ستكون هناك محاسبه
بلا شك خاصه لو ثبت ان هناك دور داخلي
امريكا في هذه المساله يعتبر اختراق قد
يكون المساله متعلقه بجاسوس داخلي في
امريكا يعتبر الامر لم يحدث خلال اخر
خمسين سنه
شكرا جزيلا لكم الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
والباحث في المركز العربي في واشنطن ولا
ريكورد مساعد ووزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق وكبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم
الامريكي شكرا جزيلا
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى هنا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]